right oh let's get the shot on the road
if everyone could just stand and we'll
do an opening prayer really quickly
excuse my terrible pronunciation and
once again here on air here here
[Music]
tapu here anahia here matu
foreign
so in English honor and glory to God
peace on Earth God will to all people
Lord develop a new heart inside of us
all and still in our sacred Spirit help
us guide us in all the things we need to
learn today amen please receded
well welcome back everyone hope everyone
had a fantastic holiday period
um I know I went away and had some time
and I think a lot of the staff did as
well seems to be quite a bit of
refreshness around the place that's even
a word so it's fantastic to see I think
we've got a really
exciting but challenging year ahead
and yeah let's crack into it with what
should be a fairly standard and regular
council meeting
so do we have any apologies it looks
wondering like everyone is here
fantastic so we will move straight into
that uh Point number two elected members
remuneration
so pretty straightforward here
obviously we need to get this done so
that we can get it off to the
remuneration Authority
did we have any questions at all
nope call uh do we have a mover for that
recommendation
uh councilor McDonald Anderson
councilor Garden
uh did we have any conversation around
the table
no fantastic I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
and those against the motion is carried
number two Council appointments for
outside organizations
um there's a large list here so I won't
go through each of the recommendations
but I will bundle them all up do we have
any questions
um for
either myself or Steve or councilor
Hotel who put this list together
uh Christian Council mcfarl
it's just regarding the district
licensing Authority group
um I don't see there's a chair appointed
there
and do we need to just do we need one on
the licensing committee
in regard to the licensing applications
three years that's fine but sometimes we
leave it open for the committee to
appoint its own chair but let's really
at the discretion of the council
Donald I'm happy to accept that if it's
there
yeah can we add that recommendation to
the list of recommendations here
um I'd also like to add the
recommendation which was missed from
this list
um which counselor MacDonald bought to
my attention the other day which is for
the equestrian
I'm forgetting the name of it now but
there's an equestrian committee as well
um and councilor McDonald was the
appointee there we just weren't sure
whether we needed a council
representative so I will get that
through you Susan as well um so that
will be included in the recommendation
do we have a mover for that grouping of
recommendations
councilor McDonald in a secondary
councilor Richard McLeod
uh any conversation around the table
I will move the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and those against
the motion is carried
nice and easy that's it
I'm